hey guys how's it going I'm sure every
single one of you have heard Gangnam
style Gangnam gang on whatever and it is
a hundred percent official at this video
has now surpassed the most viewed video
on YouTube which was justin bieber's
baby music video and I was like Gangnam
Gangnam gang is that I'll the most be oh
baby oh oh shut up Justine shut up not
my question to you guys is why do you
think this video is so popular because
I'm not really sure I saw a while ago
when my friend cat was like hey I'm
gonna make a spoof to this Gangnam style
video and I watched I was like I hate
myself you're in the Dodger by me all
machine done you do God watching the
jaja dude on back I'm not to eat myself
because I actually sort of enjoyed
watching it or the enjoyment that i got
from watching it was more enjoying the
fact that i was so confused by what the
heck am i watching but i had to watch it
again did I make any sense to you
[Music]
motto was absolutely insane is I was in
McCarthy that HIV which is the reason
that I'm really making this video
gangnam style' came on and I'm like I
don't want to hear the song again don't
want to hear it I change the station so
station change guess what's on the next
station Gangnam style change the station
again drove five different radio
stations Sirius XM whatever that
satellite nonsense a vibe infestations
what is going on I mean but I really
want to know why do you guys think of
this video so popular i'm not sure but
we've all watched and you'll see it
there were so many spoofs and i really
don't not like it it's just one of those
things that you just just like a train
wreck if you see a train wreck I promise
you you're probably gonna keep on
looking can we just take a little
timeout little Gangnam style Gangnam
style timeout shall we and I apologize
because i'm sure most of you guys are
sick of it and here i am talking about
it have a nice day
[Music]
open condom star